the current economic situation in the
united states is quite dire we saw over
the last two years that loose monetary
policy created an asset bubble and
everyone felt like they were getting
rich but now the federal reserve they've
had enough they've stepped in and they
said that they are going to destroy
demand which means that they are going
to punish the average citizen until they
stop buying consumer goods or services
why are they doing this well it's
because we have persistently high
inflation the june 2022 inflation
numbers came in it was 9.1 percent the
highest it's been in over 40 years so
what is the fed's plan to destroy
inflation well they really only have two
tools the first is that they are going
to raise interest rates going all the
way back to march of 2020 what they did
when we had the liquidity crisis related
to covid is they dropped interest rates
down to zero percent now the fed is just
reversing course and they've started to
raise interest rates when the federal
reserve raises those interest rates it
makes capital more expensive if capital
is more expensive less people want to
borrow if less people are borrowing then
that means that they have less money to
go buy things like homes or other types
of goods but the federal reserve not
only can raise interest rates they also
have a balance sheet just like you have
a personal balance sheet or your company
has a corporate balance sheet and on
that federal reserve balance sheet they
have increased their assets by more than
10x over the last decade or so the
current plan for the federal reserve is
to conduct something called quantitative
tightening where they essentially are
gonna sell assets off of the balance
sheet rather than be a persistent buyer
in the market they now claim that they
will be a seller if you take the bid
from the federal reserve out of the
market that means there's less demand
for assets and asset prices will start
to come down as we've seen over the last
eight months that the federal reserve
first it was talk and now it's action
they have been crashing asset prices
stocks bonds real estate crypto
everything continues to go down it's
because the federal reserve is in
control the old adage don't fight the
fed has a lot of truth to it as the
federal reserve conducts this
quantitative tightening as they
aggressively raise interest rates more
and more investors look around and they
say a recession may be upon us if a
recession could be coming i don't want
to spend money i don't want to be an
investor in the market what i want is
cash i want a strong balance sheet i
want strong cash flow if i'm able to
prepare myself with that strong balance
sheet and strong cash flow then just
maybe i'll be able to capitalize on
opportunity as it presents itself the
federal reserve continues to see that
9.1 percent inflation rate they don't
know how high it can go nor how long we
can stay in the sustained inflationary
environment they understand it is their
responsibility the federal reserve must
destroy inflation it's a tough task and
i hope that the federal reserve is
successful at least the people on the
ground the average family they're
counting on inflation not staying at
nine plus percent for very long